for the first time since january new
cases of coven 19 are rising again
across america driven by the highly
contagious ba2 subvarian that omicron
stealth variant is also spreading
overseas shanghai has been locked down
funeral directors in hong kong are
overwhelmed that's probably
the worst situation
that
i've ever seen in this in my
professional career
england is also seeing a dramatic spike
in new cases hospitalizations and deaths
are rising too the top white house kova
19 expert says while cases are
increasing in america the next major
wave is still months away it is likely
that we will see
a surge in the fall these are uncharted
waters for us cases are up almost 60
percent in washington d.c affecting some
of the nation's most powerful players
house speaker nancy pelosi attorney
general merrick garland and commerce
secretary gina raimondo at least 53
lawmakers staffers and journalists
tested positive after attending last
weekend's annual gridiron dinner u.s
president joe biden did not attend but
has had close contact with some who now
have the virus despite all the
precautions we take and even with the
president being double boosted he could
still test positive for kovid the white
house is urging americans to get booster
shots an independent study showed cover
19 vaccines saved 2.3 million lives in
the u.s and prevented 17 million
hospitalizations but less than 50
percent of americans have been boosted
the vaccines are just losing their
effectiveness that's why you're seeing
so many infections even in vaccinated
people but what you're not seeing is as
many deaths and hospitalizations while
many americans have grown tired of
trying to prevent copenhagen others are
keeping their guard up
i believe that it's not over yet so
i'm continuing to wear my mask dr fauci
says kobe 19 is here to stay with more
variants coming and he says vaccines may
become a yearly event similar to getting
an annual flu shot
jennifer johnson global news washington